my question was after you arrived you
observed injuries to misheard right
yes
do you remember seeing that her head was
blood
was bloody where a chunk of hair had
been ripped out of the back of her head
yeah
yes
was her head actively bleeding when you
saw her
um
it was um
it wasn't like dripping down her
her head but it was raw and red
was it actively bleeding if you remember
define actively bleeding
was there blood
yes
how could you tell hair had been ripped
out of her head
[Music]
there was a bloody patch with hair
missing was her face red
her whole face
could the redness have been from crying
it could have been
where did her nose appear to be swollen
um
it would be like the
upper bridge
did you observe that ms turd had any
black eyes
um
note that i recall
was there blood on her lips when you saw
her it was a cut open
[Music]
was there blood
coming out of that cut
sorry
um
i i don't remember there was blood
coming out of it at that point
so you testified that ms heard had a
laceration on her forehead when you saw
her
correct
yes
if you remember where on her forehead
was this laceration
go by the hairline
was it on the right or left side
[Music]
i don't
was the remember
bleeding
i don't think so
do you recognize this photograph
yes
amber's face with
swelling on her nose
bruising underneath her eyes
and to confirm you don't recognize
whether you took the photograph or not
right i i don't know if i took that one
okay i'm going to show you a document
that will be marked pennington exhibit
three
do you recognize this photograph
yes
you recognize this photograph
yeah
yes
let's pull up pennington exhibit six
do you recognize this photograph
yes
did you take this photograph
yes
what is this photograph depicting
the
part of her scalp where the hair was
ripped out
you've testified previously that you
photographed a big clump of hair on the
floor which is blonde in color and
clearly belong to amber
do you remember testifying to that
yes i remember
where did you see this clump of hair
it was um
in ph 4 in the bedroom
you